There are so many new beauty products
being released all the time,
so we gathered some of the most hyped
to test for ourselves.
This is definitely one of those
TikTok-made-me-buy-it kind of products.
This is the Pseudo Labs PHreckles Kit.
It's nothing like any other
faux-freckle product I've ever seen.
You basically get the freckle liquid,
which has a little round brush in it,
and this little toothpick-looking thing
that you use to flick
the liquid onto your face
to give you very natural-looking freckles.
I knew this was going
to be a messy process,
so I tucked a paper towel in my shirt
and just went at it.
Am I freckly?
[gasps] A little!
Right away, I was obsessed
with how the freckles came out.
It's a strange and kind of messy process,
but they do end up looking
really natural and cute.
But I highly recommend you do this topless
or with a paper towel
stuffed into your shirt.
I wanted to try the
Milani Conceal + Perfect
Smooth Finish Cream-To-Powder Foundation
because I saw people
saying this was a dupe
for the KVD Good Apple Balm.
It's not. That foundation
is literally a balm,
so it's very slippy
and almost a little oily.
This Milani one is very
thick and kind of dry.
I don't like the texture of this at all.
I do feel like this did a great job
of covering everything up,
because it is full coverage,
but it definitely emphasized
a lot of my texture,
and I don't love how it sat on my skin.
This is the ColourPop Feather
Effect Styling Brow Wax.
I got both the clear
and the tinted versions.
Also, please excuse my
purple, stained fingers.
This product is...a little strange.
I do think that it gives your brows
that fluffy, feathered look,
but I had to keep dipping in over and over
to get it to look the way I wanted it to.
The texture of this is just very odd.
Like, I had to keep checking my brush
to make sure that there
was anything even on it.
If you're looking to this
as a dupe for the ABH Brow Freeze,
I don't think this is one.
The Brow Freeze has a way softer texture
and literally does freeze your brows.
Like, they will not move.
This one has way less hold,
and it doesn't feel like it dries down.
Also, I feel like there's zero difference
in color between the tinted and the clear.
So weird.
Now let's talk about
the blush of my dreams!
The Melt Cosmetics Cream Blushlight.
You guys,
I didn't know how this was going to go
because I had already
powdered my entire face,
but I took a risk
and I just applied the blush on top,
and oh, my God.
This blush is so gorgeous,
and it didn't mess up the foundation
or powder underneath at all.
I'm in love right now.
And because I'm obviously
a huge blush lover,
I had to apply more and more and more,
and it layered beautifully.
It's totally buildable.
I fully understand now
why this has been sold out everywhere!
That's good.
These are the Danessa
Myricks Beauty Colorfix
Eye, Cheek & Lip Cream Pigments.
These are multiuse pigments, and they come
in a bunch of different
colors and finishes.
Danessa Myricks, who is a
wonderful makeup artist,
always uses these on her models
to create, like, the most beautiful looks,
so I was dying to try them.
These pigments are no joke.
Literally one drop is all you need.
I definitely used too
much, but I'm so impressed
not only by how pigmented they are,
but how many ways you can use them.
I used them for under-eye corrector,
blush, eyeliner, and lipstick.
Once these dry down,
they're definitely staying put.
This was not my best makeup work,
but I was just having a good time
playing around with these.
Minimal, skinlike makeup is
kind of like the norm now,
and this Fenty Beauty Eaze
Drop Blurring Skin Tint
totally makes sense for the time.
It's actually way less liquidy
than I imagined it to be.
And, as expected, the
coverage was pretty minimal,
but this skin tint is super buildable,
so I just added more where
I felt like I needed it.
Highly recommend using a brush
if you want to get the
most coverage out of it.
The finish is pretty nice,
and it does dry down,
so you don't have to
worry about any tackiness.
I am just so not a
skin-tint kind of person,
but this one gives you that
your-skin-but-better look
that I think a lot of
people would be into.